Hello and welcome to Teaching and Learning with
RStudio Cloud. My name is Mine Çetinkaya-Rundel.
I am a professional educator and a data scientist
with RStudio, as well as a professor of the
practice at Duke University in the Statistical
Science department. I've been teaching and learning
R in RStudio for many, many years now and
over the last few years I've really enjoyed
being able to teach with RStudio Cloud.  In this
webinar I want to talk to you a little bit about
what RStudio Cloud is, how you can teach and
learn with it, and I want to particularly highlight
some of the new developments in RStudio Cloud
that I think would be of interest to educators.
The webinar will be streamed live on YouTube,
and I will be also answering questions during
the live stream. So if you think of any questions
as we're going through things please put them in
the chat and I will be there to answer them. And
you can also see a link on the slides rstd.io/tl-rscloud,
and that's where you can
find the PDF of the slides as well.
So let's start with what is RStudio Cloud?
RStudio Cloud is a lightweight cloud-based
solution that allows anyone to do, share, teach, and
learn data science online in the browser, so all
you need is a computer with an internet connection
and a browser to be able to start computing with R.
You do not actually need to install anything. So
there's nothing to configure, no dedicated
hardware, and no installation. That's what I think
makes it really easy for students to get started
with computing, and that's what makes RStudio Cloud an attractive choice for teaching.
So let's talk a little bit about RStudio
Cloud. This is what RStudio Cloud looks like
when you've logged on. So over here you can see a
little link that says New Project. And I'm going
to click on that, and iIm going to select New
RStudio Project. This takes a second to deploy
a project, which is basically the same as an RStudio Project. I can give it a name in the web
user interface, and the rest of it is basically
the RStudio IDE that you're accustomed to. You
can see that Ican start computing right away. So
let's start by asking the question, why might we
want to use RStudio in the cloud? If we are
actually teaching with a local installation,
the students when they first come to class they
would need to first install R and then install
RStudio, and then maybe install a bunch of packages
that you're going to use, then load these packages.
If you're teaching with version control they will
also need to install git, and that has a lot of
potential friction points. Maybe some steps are
easier than others, but if we were to actually
try to go through each of these steps with the
audience right now we probably wouldn't be able to
get through it so quickly. On the other hand, when
you are teaching with RStudio Cloud, what you
can tell your students is go to rstudio.cloud,just log in, and start coding. Much less friction
to get started with. So how might you access RStudio in the Cloud? You have a couple options. Your
first option is using RStudio Workbench, which
is basically a professional product offered by
RStudio. This requires that you yourself as
an educator either have some sysadmin experience,
or you have some IT support who can help you set
this up. You also need either a hardware to
run this piece of software, a local virtual
machine, or some cloud computing credits. Because
your students are going to be computing
somewhere, and that needs to happen either
in the cloud where you're paying for it, or
you have credit for it, or on a local hardware.
Obviously you also need to have RStudio
experience, because you are teaching with RStudio.
If this actually defines you well,
RStudio makes RStudio Workbench
and licenses it for free as part of their academic
pricing. So you can go to rstudio.com/pricing/academic-pricing.
And you can read a
little bit about it. I think they want something
like a syllabus to show that you're going to
be using this for teaching, and you can get that.
And if this is of interest to you we actually
have a paper in the American Statistician called
Infrastructure and Tools for Teaching Computing
Throughout the Statistical Curriculum, where we
go into the details of how you can set this up for
your students. But as you saw there's lots that's
needed to be able to get started with this, and
if you neither have the sysadmin experience or
you don't have the IT support available to
you, this may be a little bit out of reach.
With RStudio Cloud really all you need to
have is RStudio experience and nothing else.
So i think that's one thing that makes it quite
attractive as an educator, especially if you're
teaching statistics or data science, you may not
have this sysadmin experience. Or you may not have
the resources listed there to be able to run this
stuff locally. So next question is fine, maybe
I've convinced you that teaching your students
how to use R in RStudio in the Cloud is
a good idea. That they should be just going to
their web browser and starting doing computing.
Why RStudio Cloud then, and maybe not some
other option? Well let's talk about RStudio
Cloud in a nutshell. We already said that it does
not require IT experience to set up. It also has
some features designed for teaching. For example,
you can organize your classes as a workspace.
You can leverage roles, so you can have different
roles for your instructor, yourself, your teaching
assistants, or your students. You can turn projects
into assignments, which is using vocabulary your
students are familiar with. You can actually peek
into student projects, which is hugely helpful
when you're trying to help them out - especially
remotely. And you can ensure the same setup for
all the student projects using the concept of a
base project that we'll touch on in a little bit.
Additionally certain system libraries work out of
the box. Like you can, you know, get started with git
without actually having to install it. And you
can knit to PDF and Word out of the box as well,
as opposed to having your students, you know,
having locally set up something like LaTeX or
having access to Microsoft Word. Let's talk
a little bit about Projects in RStudio Cloud,
which is basically how we encapsulate our work
and how we organize it. There are three types of
projects. The first one is the RStudio Project that
we have already seen. We had created this project. I
have named it "my first rstudio project". I've also
shown you that, you know, you can do plotting and
whatnot. It's basically the IDE you're familiar
with, and we're typing our code here. An alternative
is a Jupyter Project. This is a new feature.
And it's in beta, so there may be changes to
it. There will probably be updates to it. We can
go to the same menu and choose a Jupyter Project.
And you can see that you're basically
finding yourself in a Jupyter Notebook.
And you can launch it and, you know, you can start
running some Python code there as well. Now you
can also run Python code in the RStudio
IDE via the reticulate package. So this is not the
only way that you could be using RStudio Cloud
for teaching Python. But using Jupyter Notebooks
is beyond just teaching Python. This is just one
example where you're actually running Python code.
Additionally you can start a project from a git
repository. This is something I use very regularly.
Because I teach using git and GitHub, I teach git
as a version control system. But we also use
GitHub as kind of our learning management system.
Every assignment is a repository for my students.
And so they go to GitHub first, grab their
private repository that's named to them, and then
they bring in the files that I have put in that
repository to get started. That's basically doing
a git clone, if you're familiar with that language.
In order to do this in RStudio Cloud I can
again click on New Project, say New Project from
git, and paste the URL of the project. I'm going to
simply clone the praise package that basically
generates some random praise that you can use
in your work, or in your other packages. And you can
see that basically we've cloned that project. And I
can continue working with this. The RStudio
IDE already provides a git tab for me anyway,
as soon as it recognizes that this
is a git version-controlled project.
And I can start interacting with it
that way, and push and pull to GitHub.
All right. So we've talked about
the three ways that you could be
working in RStudio Cloud and creating projects,
so let's talk a little bit about teaching with
RStudio Cloud. I tend to think of my teaching
experiences in one of these two kind of
,types either shorter engagement teaching or
longer engagement teaching. What I mean by shorter
engagement teaching is it's maybe a workshop, like
a couple hours, a short course at a conference for
four hours or maybe even a full day. But more
importantly than time perhaps is the amount of
content, where content I think can be organized
in one or just a few projects that I could
share with my learners. And additionally in this
kind of engagement I'm generally not interested
in keeping track of my learner. So I don't have
things like, have students completed their homework?
Or maybe I don't, after the teaching engagement is
over, I have a need to go peek into their project
to provide additional support to them. If
this is the case I would recommend that you
use kind of the simpler approach of just
share a single project with your learners.
If we're thinking about a longer engagement, for me
that's usually a semester-long course, a multi-day
workshop, or something like that. And again from
the content perspective, where content can be best
organized in multiple projects. Additionally I want
to keep track of my learners. I want to know who
my students are. I want to know if they're in my
workspace. I want to know if they've started their
work. I want to be able to provide guidance to them
by sometimes peeking into their projects. If this
defines your teaching engagement, then the approach
where you invite your students to a workspace
where you have organized the content is, I think,
a better approach. So let's start with a slightly
simpler one where I said would be, I believe,
better suited for a shorter engagement teaching.
In this case we're sharing an RStudio Cloud
project. And we'll give the example of a single
RStudio Cloud project. But as I said, you know, if
it's just two or three of them and you want to
share them individually that's probably not too
confusing for your learners, versus in a longer
engagement you might have 10 homework assignments
and 10 labs and a project and whatnot. And you
probably don't want to individually share links
for each and every one of those. So how does this
go? We're going to be looking at the instructor
view now. So I am in-- I have created in
RStudio Cloud a single project. And I have named it
Introduction to Shiny. You can see that on the top
left corner of my screen. And you can see that
I've created this project in what is called Your
Workspace. So this is my personal workspace. And
there I've created a project called Introduction
to Shiny, which let's say is the short course that
I'm going to teach at a conference. In the Files
tab you can see that I have created some folders
where I've organized the content. So if we take a
look at one of those folders, let's start with the
first module. Maybe I have some slides. I have an
app in there that the students are going to work
with, a few other app examples that iIm going to
teach with. Since i'm teaching Shiny I definitely
want to install the shiny package, probably other
packages too. But to keep things simple let's
also install the shiny package. So in this project
I have installed the Shiny package now. And let's
also just confirm that it's been installed. One
thing I'd like to do is i just try to load the
package. Does that work? Let's do library(shiny).
That seems to be working okay. And I'm gonna say
we're good to go and share this content with the
students. So you can see all the structure for
the workshop is there. I'm gonna click on that
little gear icon, go to Access, and for who can
view this project i'm going to say everyone.
And then I am going to go up to the URL and simply
copy that link. That's it. That's all I need to
share this content with my students. And you can
see that by using a nice kind of folder structure.
I've been able to organize the material for
them. I like naming my folders in this way so
learners know where we're at at each point
of a workshop, for example. So I've copied
the URL after making the project available
to everyone. So as soon as I turn that switch
it is, you know, available to the whole
world. Although who will be able to find
that project? It's very unlikely that someone
can stumble upon it unless I share the link with
them. On the student view now they receive that URL
from their instructor. And so they go to their URL
bar and simply paste it. And what they do is they
need to now log in. So they're going to log in
to our RStudio Cloud. You can log in with Google, for
example. And they can start computing. They see the
same folder structure, everything that I gave them
is there. Remember we installed the Shiny package?
They're able to load it. So they don't have to
reinstall it again. That's already there for them.
They can see the content I've prepared for them.
They could even right away go ahead and run the
app, for example. From the student's perspective
this is a really nice way of getting started, right?
We really didn't have to teach them, or at least
spend time during the workshop, which is about
Introduction to Shiny in this hypothetical
case, about how to set things up for them.
So let's talk a little bit about this notion
of sharing a single RStudio Cloud project
to disseminate your teaching materials. On the
plus side, students land directly in a project
upon login, right? They get the URL and they're in the RStudio IDE, which I think is perfect.
It's great for sharing code in general, too. So
I tend to think about this approach not just in
the context of teaching, but also in the context of
collaboration. Or you know sometimes you have this
reproducible example that's not quite minimal, that still perhaps takes a lot of code, and
you really want someone to be able to dive into
your computing environment and see what you're
doing. That's what it's also great for, just being
able to share your entire environment with them.
On the potentially minus side, I don't know
if your eye caught that, but on the top of
the window in the student view you
could see in red the words temporary copy. So
students need to remember to make a permanent
copy of the project you share with them. And
they can do that.That red, you know,
text blinks. That hopefully gets their
attention. And there's a little button right
next to it that says save a permanent copy.
But really what I mean by this bullet point
is that it is on you as the instructor to
remind them to do that. Because as soon as they make a
permanent copy their work will be saved. They could
close their browser window. They could lose power.
It doesn't matter. They can come back and pick
up where they left off. However if they have not
made the permanent copy and started working on it
and then they close their window they're going
to actually lose their work. And there's nothing
more frustrating to a student than that. So this
is totally avoidable. But you as the instructor
will need to remind them. You can't keep track
which students started their assignments. So this
URL just goes out into the world, and anyone who
has access to that can use it. But you don't
have a way of monitoring who has made copies
of your project and started their assignment.
If a student wants help from you in a way where
they would want you to peek into their project
you need to be granted permission in order to
be able to do that. So that's an additional step
for the students to have to do. Now there are two
other bullet points I want to discuss. And these
could be pluses for some of you and minuses for
others. These permanent projects-- once a student
makes a permanent project-- count towards
the student's free hours on RStudio Cloud.
for some this might be okay. Because maybe you
are teaching in a situation where you are not
going to be kind of responsible for the cost of
the compute your learners are going to be. So in
that case this might be okay. Chances are if you're
teaching in a university setting, for example, where
students, you know, have already paid for the
course and do not expect to incur additional
charges, they probably would not want to be put
in a situation where they have a limited number
of free hours to work on their assignment. We want
students to be work-- working on things
as long as they want to and not have these kind of
artificial limits on their learning. Additionally
students control permissions. Is this a good
thing or a bad thing? iI again depends. If you're
teaching in a graded course you may not want this
because it's a too easy a way perhaps for them to
share their work with their classmates, which
might constitute some sort of academic misconduct.
But you might be teaching in a little
workshop where this is perfectly fine. So again,
depending on your situation, these could be
pros or cons. Let's talk also about inviting
to an RStudio Cloud workspace, which is the second
method of sharing your materials that I mentioned,
which is for longer engagement projects. So
here what we're going to do on the instructor
view is you can see this is my account. I have
a bunch of projects to myself in my workspace.
But I'm going to click on the little kind of
hamburger menu there, open the sidebar ,and create
a new space. Let's say I'm teaching a longer
workshop called Shiny Essentials. This was a
two day workshop I taught this year, so I figured
I'd reuse that name. And here I can see there's
nothing in that workspace yet. I can create a new
RStudio project. And I can name it something.
Maybe let's just name it 01 Getting started.
Again say that's going to be the first module
in this particular longer workshop that I'm giving.
So here again we have an RStudio Cloud project. And
I can change the access level to everyone. But this
time it's not everyone in the world, it's everyone
in this workspace. And I'm going to turn it into
an assignment. So now when the students get invited
to my workspace and land here they're going to see
that they have some assignments they need to start
working on. This is not to say it's like homework.
It's just something they can get started with.
And in fact on the student view they see the word
start instead of the word assignment there.
You can see from a different-- so
a workshop that i actually did give
that was designed in this way, for each
of the assignments that I have created
I can see the derived project. So I could actually
click on there and peek into students projects.
And this is a good way-- the summary statistics
here are a good way of gauging for you how many
students have started. But also you can deep down--
dive deeper and look into their projects. Which
is really nice, especially if they need help and
you're teaching remotely and can't just kind of
peek over their shoulder. In the Members tab of a
workspace that you create, like this, you have some
options. You have some options about how you want
to invite students to your workspace. I generally
use the sharing link. So it creates a single link.
And I can pick a role for people who come into the
workspace using that link. And we'll say more about
the roles in a second. And simply either email that
out. Or if iIm teaching, you know, share that during
the first few minutes of the teaching engagement.
I've covered some names up here too, in order not to
show the real students names on the webinar. But
you can basically see that that would be how you
can keep track of who is in your workspace. So the
four roles that are available are admin, moderator,
contributor, and viewer. And they have different
permission levels. So admin is probably you. And
you can do everything, including managing users.
A moderator is usually the level of access I
give my teaching assistants. They can view and
edit and manage all projects. So
they can go in and help students,
but they don't end up managing the users, the
actual students who get admitted into the place.
Contributors are basically students who
can only see their work. And then viewers
I generally use that for like an auditor in a
course. Or sometimes a guest, like a colleague,
will say, "I'd like to see how you're doing things."
But I don't necessarily want them to see the list
of students, you know, in my course in the-- in
the members tab. So I give them that lowest level
of access. We can also set permissions. These
boxes will be unchecked by default. And I would
encourage you to be carefully thinking about
checking them. So do you want your contributors
to see the members list? You know if you're
teaching a public course maybe not. Maybe
if it's a small university course and you want
everyone to know each other's names, maybe you do.
Whether or not contributors, so that's students, can
make their projects visible to all members, again
we discuss this notion of potential academic
misconduct that could happen by students being
able to too easily share their work. Perhaps, you
know, not checking that box is not going to protect
you from, you know, everything that could go wrong.
But we don't want to potentially be additionally
making things easy for students if the way the
course is set up is such that they shouldn't
see each other's work. Or if it is that they should
be able to, then we could allow them to change that.
And the third one is about whether they can change
project resources. And that's getting into things
like the memory and the compute that they're going
to use, which gets tied into the pricing, which
we'll say a couple things about at the very end.
So think about these permission levels. But it's
good to know that these are there, that you-- and you
can toggle based on your own teaching situation.
We also mentioned this notion of a base project.
So here in the workspace I've clicked on the gear
icon for the workspace itself, where I could
rename my course if i wanted to. But underneath
it you can see that I can set a base RStudio
project. So these base projects include-- they're
basically an any old RStudio Cloud project
that you kind of delegate as the base project.
This is where you can define the R
version that will be used for all projects,
what packages will be installed, and if there's
any certain files that you want repeated across
all of the projects in the course. For me this
is usually not data because i usually tend to
change, you know, data files from assignment to
assignment. But it's usually things like a code
of conduct, maybe submission instructions, things
that will stay constant throughout the assignment.
And you can update it as many times as you like,
which is really great. Because if you, you know, if
there's a new package comes out or a package gets
updated and you want to change things up in the
middle of the semester, you can go back and do
that. And your changes are not retroactive, for
a good reason. You don't want to mess up students
work that happened prior to that time point. So any
changes you make will only affect projects
that are created after that change was made.
So inviting in our-- inviting your students to
an RStudio Cloud workspace, lots of pluses in
my opinion, various permission levels, this notion
of base projects with desired packages installed,
the notion of assignments, which remove the need
to remind students to make a copy of the project
before starting work, and this ability to peek into
student projects. Maybe on the minus side one thing
I can think of is that when students land in the
workspace they don't actually land in the RStudio
IDE, right? They need to do an additional thing to
figure out which project to go into next. So they
may need instructions, like start the assignment
titled getting started, or something like that.
Easy enough to handle, but something you need to
remember as the instructor. And again on could be a
pro, could be a con side, student's work now counts
towards your, you know, this could be you as an
instructor or your institution that might be
paying for the particular level of RStudio
Cloud for the workspace hours. And that could be
a positive or it could be a negative, depending
on your situation. An instructor controls the
permissions, and again depending on the teaching
engagement type you have that may be a positive or
a negative. I tend to find that for my University
teaching these are both pros for me. But for
other types of teaching engagements that might be
different. Let's wrap things up with a few tips for
teaching with RStudio Cloud. So one, the first is
that when you-- changes to an assignment a student
has started won't propagate to the student copy. So if
you've set up an assignment for your students
and then realize there was a typo, or you forgot
to add a data file, you're not going to be able to
just change things up and then let it propagate.
Once the students start their assignment they're
actually making a copy of that assignment, like at
that snapshot of time point. So you're going
to need to get that information to them in some
other way. If you're teaching with git you could
be updating the GitHub repositories and they could
simply pull the changes from there. Otherwise maybe
you reach out to your students in some other way
to let them know of the corrections. Packages
in the base project are installed, but they're
not loaded. So don't forget those library commands in the assignments that you give to the students.
The latest information is always on the RStudio
Cloud guide and the What's New page. And you can
get to these from the hamburger menu on
the left side of your RStudio Cloud
window. So if you're thinking, "how do I do x?" the
guide is probably the first place to look at.
And if you encounter any sort of slowness or
glitches, you know projects not starting up as
quickly as they used to, the first place to
check is the system status. So you can take--
again you can from the left hand menu you
can get under help to the current system status.
And if there is an outage that will be noted there.
If there isn't but you're still experiencing this,
or your students are experiencing it,
then, you know, reach out to support
to let them know. If you-- I would strongly
recommend creating an additional account
and logging in as a student to see what they see.
Because what you see is not always what they see.
And it's nice to be able to assure yourself that
you've set things up the right way. Especially
the first few times you're teaching with a new
technology. Test assignments to set sufficient
computational resources. These are toggles that you
can change. So you can see those little toggles on
the side here. So make sure that you test to
make sure that you know the data size
you have, or the computation you're asking your
students will actually work with the allocated
kind of RAM and the CPUs. And if not you
will be able to toggle those up if you want.
The whole peeking at your students project
feature is fantastic but you, I believe you
might want to use that sparingly. Or at least
I try to use that sparingly. Because the first
thing that I want to get my students to do is
to learn to articulate the issues they're having
without me going in and fixing it for them. That
being said, sometimes they may not have the right
vocabulary if they're for-- especially if they're,
you know, very new to computing, to R and RStudio.
So it's nice to be able to you know push them
to articulate things. But if that's not getting
anywhere and people are getting frustrated, or the
students is getting frustrated it's really nice to
be able to peek in. And it's additionally helpful
for remote teaching situations, as you can imagine.
The assignment feature, even though the word
is assignment, I try not to think of it as just
homework. I also try to think of it as, you know, if
I'm going to be doing some live coding in class
iId like to write out a skeleton for
myself where I will be filling in the
code. And I use that feature to share
that code starter with the students
so that some of them, if they actually want to code
along with me, they have that to get started with.
A couple other useful resources, there is
now a nice playlist with 14 very short
and informative videos about how to do much of
what i talked about and more with RStudio
Cloud. And there's a short link for it on the
top of the screen: rstd.io/cloud-playlist.
So you can take a look at those and watch through
them. And if you are going to be using RStudio
Cloud for teaching or for other purposes where you
think there will be heavy usage, lots of students,
or maybe lots of projects take a look at the
pricing options. There is always a free option.
Although as soon as you're thinking about a
classroom with a substantial number of students
the free option may not be the right one for
you-- may not be sufficient anymore. So I would
recommend especially taking a look at the Cloud
Instructor pricing plan, and also reaching out
to the RStudio sales folks who work on this to
just describe your situation of number of students
and the type of course you're teaching to let them
help you help guide you to figure out the best
pricing option for you. Thank you very much for
tuning in, and I will hang out a little bit in the
chat on YouTube as well to answer your questions.
Once again you can find the slides at rstd.io/tl-rscloud
if you'd like to see a PDF
version of those as well. Have a great day!